good evening
and welcome to this meeting of the
development committee I will now read
out the emergency evacuation
announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm goes off please leave the
building in an orderly fashion through
the nearest fire exit
please use either the fire exit exit
through the main doors of the hall or
the fire exit in a store room adjacent
to the stage
the far assembly point is that the
island in front of the main entrance of
the building
please do not delay your evacuations to
collect any belongings please do not
return to the building unless given
permission to do so by Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded please switch off mobiles
or turn them to silent please note that
toilet and hand washing facilities are
in the foyer
members of the public are amen
um of course I do apologize members of
the public are reminded that this is an
official council meeting and the item
before us will be debated according to
the usual Council rules for Council
meetings to which the public are omitted
members of the public are not permitted
to speak at the meeting unless they are
previously registered to speak with
Democratic services
in this way everyone present will be
able to hear the debate and councilors
will be able to make an informed
decision
[Music]
can someone at the back please close the
back the door for me please show me
getting up and doing it thank you very
much
is
members this is now 7 30. the meeting
will commence
members there is a need to use
microphones during this meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphone phones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording members you'll notice
there isn't isn't stand so you will need
to hold it as if you were singing but
please don't go into karaoke
like these are all switched on and ready
for you to speak and will be unmuted by
offices for you please make sure that
the microphone is directly in front of
your mouth before speaking
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the Constitution
I will ask for a show of hands for and
then against recommendations and would
also ask for a show of hands for those
wishing to abstain from voting
agenda item one and two apologies for
absence and substitutes we have received
apologies for absence from councilor
Foster Milne and Williams councilor
Steptoe will be substituting for
councilor Foster councilor Webb will be
substituting for councilor Milne and
councilor sparian will be substituting
for councilor Williams
agenda 3 non-members attending
regardless
we have uh counts
councilor with him councilor lambaum
councilman person Mrs Squires Coleman
Miss
Mr Wilson
Mr accounts the Hawaii councilor sharp
councilor Wilson councilor Ward have I
missed any more members as a hand sorry
Council Council across anyone else from
RDC
no thank you
members
minutes of uh the meeting uh are held on
the 14th of 2022 is this agreed
thank you members
agenda 5 to receive dick prices of
Interest I have a declaration of
interest on a non-fur Cooney one
for item
six seven
eight I will I am not allowed to sit on
this committee I will excuse myself and
my vice chairman counselor FD will take
that part of
um the agenda
are there any other um Declarations of
Interest please counselor Webb
thank you chairman uh non-pecuniary
interest for item eight on the vice
chair of the pizza at Hope Farm junior
school thank you thank you very much
councilor Steptoe
thank you chair
um declare an interest as um Essex
County councilor both items eight and
nine fall within my division thank you
very much councilor Steptoe
oh sorry FD
non-pecuni interest on item a and Oxford
Parish councilor and
item 1931 burning roads I'm a great way
Queen Parish counselor
accounts counselor and also Deputy
Cabinet member for highways
members given the large numbers of
residents intenders tonight in
accordance with committee procedure rule
9C I'd like to move a motion without
notice to change the order
our business on the agenda item six
item 6879 and 10A in effect moving item
8. to the second application considered
do I have a second to please
councilor FD is it can I have a vote is
this in agreement please members
thank you
is there anyone against this motion
anyone of staining no
that's unanimous thank you members
agenda item six a 22 stroke double zero
double zero six stroke fall Grove Road
uh Grovewood Primary School Grove Road
Rayleigh our Evans will present the
officer's report over to you Orwell
please
[Music]
testing thank you chairman
this application as stated in section
2.1 of the officer's report relates to
material operations on land involving
the physical operations of of
constructing a synthetic all-weather
multi-use games area the erection of a
three meter high boundary metal fence
slight alteration in land levels
drainage works and Landscaping works
fundamentally the application is
development for this reason only as
defined by section 55 of the Town and
Country planning act and not on the
basis that any material change of use is
involved this point is emphasized that
paragraph 2.2 of the officer's report
the first slide
just shows the context of the site so
the red line defines the application
site boundary we'll move on to some
slides shortly that shows the specific
location of the mugger
just to say that the School site is
allocated within the allocations plan
2014 for educational purposes and also
the site here is also designated
Metropolitan green belts
we'll move on to slide two please
so I'm just going to indicate that in
terms of its location the site so in
terms of orientation generally it's
north
south west east that's the orientation
so members will see that
properties along Clarence Road have
spacious Gardens backing on to part of
the school site here
so the mugger itself is located within
this area here
with this additional area being used for
the deposition of a small volume of soil
which will be graded into the land and
is a slight assure that in a minute
and basically you've got raised levels
along here which is Warwick
Warwick Drive and Warwick greens are
like a cul-de-sac here and I was walking
the site it's obvious that actually
the properties to the South are on
raised land levels relative to the site
so the site actually rests in a bit of a
hollow
we'll move on to slide three please
there we go I'm just going to talk
through the plans so this is a plan of
the site layout superimposed on an
aerial image so you can see the rear of
the properties at Clarence Road and then
this is the area where there'll be some
soil the position and you can see there
this gray line here is a cycle track
that's been constructed at the school so
the outer white line denotes the actual
boundary of where the actual metal
fencing will be
spare with me yes I'm just going to
depict the overall pitch length as the
report indicates is 61 meters in length
by 43 meters in width and these are the
requirements are set out by Sports
England paragraph 2.3 of the officer
reports sets out how the pitch will be
used to facilitate a number of sporting
opportunities including football and
netball
the yeah the crescent-shaped area here
is where there'll be some more
additional tree planting as well
and we'll move on to slide four please
so this is just a plan showing it again
where there's some tree planting here
and you can see the the definitive
boundaries of the properties of Clarence
Road this is just like a notional red
lines showing sort of access from the
school but this isn't for public use so
that just shows that
you know people will be traveling in
through the school buildings or through
the main car park to the to the muga
area
so I've got to slide five please
again so that's self-explanatory really
but it's basically what it shows is is
that you've got a large football pitch
haven't you that can do 11 aside you've
got then smaller pitches
um for different age groups that are
smaller in in sort of surface area to
accommodate seven aside and eight aside
and that kind of thing we'll move on to
slide six please
writes the this slide is quite important
really this was provided on our request
so just to give you some distances
really so the this black outer line is
where the actual metal fencing will be
um there were concerns raised by some of
the Neighbors in terms of the impact of
this fence Etc so at this point here
this is 8.24 the fence relative to the
boundary at the rear of Clarence Road
but the boundary tapers that is broadly
14.60 meters and then
further away that you get it's 43 meters
to the boundary there so there's quite a
significant area of land here that's
been kept open so the the mugger is you
know not within sort of 50 meters of
those three of the properties at Warwick
green but it is closer to the real the
properties at Clarence Road we'll move
on to slide seven please
this slide basically just depicts the um
elevations of the fence relative to
ground levels so the the main difference
is
um to the north elevation where you can
see the land basically Falls from
South West to Northeast and and these
sort of these fence elevations account
for the slight change in land levels but
basically this point here this the
changes are sort of two to three hundred
mils so a foot in the old-fashioned
measurements
you just have a look
um we'll move on to slide eight please
so this actually is is quite an
important slide that talks about the
actual surfacing itself so it is a
permeable surface so it's not some
surface that
rain water falls and it just pools on
there so it doesn't explain
um there's this relatively
self-explanatory so we've got the the
carpet layer at the top
we've got then the pad underneath it
we've then got the Macadam the 40 mil
Macadam we've got then got 250 mil
hardcore material and at the base you've
got a network of of perforated pipe I
think it's at about 150 300 nil diameter
perforated pipes in a herringbone
pattern that drains the water from that
site into
um another drain and we'll go on to
slide nine please
yeah so this this this plan here just
that what we've got here some spot
Heights and basically what it shows is
is that in terms of land levels the
highest raising the land level is in
this area here so that is relative to
the existing ground level here and the
existing ground level here which is the
same there'd be a small
almost in the cernal incline so you're
talking about a difference of between
this point here and this point here 430
millimeters of foot
and 13 centimeters really and then it
Peters down again to this point here and
then the section drawing
um at slide 10 shows and I'll just talk
you through this if we can
get the box at the top in please the
sections A and B B
so if you bring that in
so
so this is section A A
so this is looking north to south which
is this one here
so we're looking through the site and
what it shows basically is is the land
level rises from here
and then it reaches a higher Point here
the 430 mil difference
and then b b is this one here the south
of the path so looking through that BB
would be this one again so quite
relatively it's the highest building up
of the soil is in the middle part here
and it's and actually on Section cc is
actually almost sort of quite
indiscernable really so but those are
the sections just to show you that
on-site what I would say is is those
raised levels
they're very minor on engineering
operations really
so I'm just going to move on now to the
summary of issues just to close the
sites in the metropolitan green belt
one of the questions that the officers
reports raised was whether it was an
appropriate development this was
discussed at 335-337 officers report
and it was concluded there was no
identified definitional harm on the
question of inappropriateness
neither is there any harm as discussed
the paragraph 338 to 3.40 of the report
in terms of visual and spatial harm
the use itself clarification has been
provided further on this matter at
paragraph 3.41 345 and paragraph 3.44
confirms that the limitation of the use
as conditions as conditioned aligns with
the current Arrangements limiting hours
of use is a separate consideration which
has covered up paragraph 3.46 the
officers view that limiting hours of the
use of an application which itself is
not a change of use would amount to the
LPA exceeding the scope of its legal
Powers I.E in Latin Ultra values there
is no floodlighting the application
doesn't propose it use of all artificial
lighting is prohibited due to the
recognition that floodlighting would
potentially have impacts which would
need to be properly assessed so there is
a condition making it clear that this
permission would not allow the use of
temporary floodlighting based on a on a
wheelbase or
you know attached to the ground the
impact among characters discussed at 3.9
of which there is no impact the impact
on residential amenities covered at
paragraph 3.50 which discusses which
discusses this matter and I think the
important thing is is as there's no
material change of use there is no
trigger to generate greater noise levels
and this is discussed at 3.51 the
objection of Neighbors on this aspect is
discussed Sports England's position a
paragraph
3.62 to 3.67 refers to the benefits of
the development supporting the
conclusion of an objection as proposals
meets exception five where there is a
loss of parts of a School playing field
but the benefits of the facility
outweigh the loss of the grass and the
fact that scenario brass and psychopath
will still exist the surface water
drainage the site plan this is the last
plan actually this plan basically what
it shows is herringbone pattern pipework
lying beneath that hardcore it's then
diverted into a capturing drainage and
there's a flow control valve here which
controls the flow of the water before
it's actually discharged into an
attenuation tank and then the the surf
the water then is discharged the river
orch at a point 250 meters to the north
of the site
so we're just going to conclude now and
come to a summary
we've noted a paragraph 3.84 to 3.5 to
take account of the objections and I
think there's about there's many pages
that list the objections we acknowledge
those
um
3.97 to 1.3.101 covers the appeal
decision at fits ymax school which was
raised by
um an individual there is a there is a
difference between fitzwai Mac
um appeal that was dismissed that was
for commercial hire this application is
not
it had flight it had flood lighting this
app proposal had does not
they were considerable there was
considered to be noise disturbance as a
result of that change of use supporting
the reasons to dismiss the appeal none
of those issues material to decision in
this case apply
this is covered up paragraph 3.102 to
3.103 of the report so it is my
recommendation that this Suffocation
constitutes sustainable development
and it's the recommendation that
conditional consent be granted subject
to the conditions cited at the head of
the report which include that condition
three a condition clarifying the
limitations of use and that condition
for a condition prohibiting the sighting
and use of any artificial Lighting in
the interest of a residential amenity
Jacob's ready Town Council uh can you
come up on the corner please uh
councilor Jacobs you have five minutes
and we will advise you uh and it will be
a bit distracting because we'll be
saying you've got one minute left okay
thank you
thank you madam chairman and good
evening councilors I speak on behalf of
and as a representative of the Rayleigh
Town Council as the chairman for its
planning committee
regarding the planned application on the
grounds of Grovewood Primary School
which would seek the appropriation of
land in order to install an artificial
grass Sports pitch with an enclosing
boundary fence and to form a bond
through the removal of topsoil
councilors on the 4th of July the
Rayleigh Town Council planning committee
called back the planning application
follow following an initial decision to
defer due to concerns regarding the area
potentially being hired out for
commercial reasons
in our called in scrutiny of the
application it became apparent to
members there was a real and serious
lack of impact assessments being made
for this application our concerns
included the following
Sports England held a Holden
objection to this application due to
their checklist not being completed by
the applicant a lack of an assessment
into the viability of this application
in accordance to align with the national
planning policy framework the Essex
Green infrastructure strategy and your
council's policies
alongside this surface water and flood
assessments also appeared to be absent
at the time
and may also note that the application
is made on land which is in a high risk
area for surface water flooding
no noise assessment was made at this
time note in sports sport England's
research alongside that of the world
health organizations of 58 decibels of
equivalent continuous sound pressure
levels alongside that of the Whos of 50
decibels for the upper noise limit
external to Residential Properties
it seems apparent that there would also
be no attempt to mitigate and reduce the
noise impact on local residents also
noting that Clarence Road is less than
10 meters away
it could be highly likely that this
would be an adverse impact on residents
in the sake of time I will also briefly
highlight the lack of abide biodiversity
assessment bats of a tree impact or an
oracultural report
councilors and these were the main
reasons as to our decision to reject the
application but may I note and also
Express that our initial decision was
not to object but rather to defer
judgments until these assessments were
completed but as deferral was not an
option in this instance the Rayleigh
Town Council had to object as far as I'm
aware the only assessment made since the
sin on the 4th of July was that before
sustainable drainage systems
with the technical report provided by
the applicant's statement that it is
just within the legal limits for service
water flooding but then state if it does
flood then water can pond in the field
away from the school buildings
now with this first hand that the Roger
District Council has had some issues in
relaying information solely to the
planning committee of the Rayleigh Town
Council in which I am sure but if any
further information has come to light I
would be most grateful if either the
clerk or I could be informed thank you
thank you very much
there's a member of the public that is
actually filming tonight we have no
objections that but they needed to put
their hand up and if they did I'm sorry
but can I ask you to come and sit at the
front please
I have no problem with you filming but
you should have put your hand up and I
did if you did I did miss you I still
apologize and but if you could sit at
the front thank you very much
thank you very much councilor to Jacobs
the second item uh person we've got is
Mr Richard green head teacher Grove wood
Primary School in support of the
application again you will have five
minutes and you're used to interruptions
that I'll give you a mini okay thank you
thank you chairman good evening
councilors good evening my name is
Richard green and I'm very proud to be
the head teacher of Grovewood Primary
School Grovewood is a very special
school every member of staff is
committed to ensuring that all of our
pupils are given the very best start to
their education and underpinning
everything we do lies our commitment to
providing opportunities sharing
experiences and making memories
we believe that successful education is
far more than the set of academic
outcomes and we pride ourselves on the
wide range of curricula and
extracurricular opportunities that we're
able to offer
these include a wide range of sporting
artistic musical cultural clubs as well
as some more diverse and Innovative
clubs including Birds of Prey scenes of
crime and green power whereby the
children have the opportunity to build
kit cars and race them at iconic
racetracks such as Goodwood currently we
offer our pupils approximately 50
extracurricular clubs a week
wood is the largest of the schools in
Essex local Authority currently there
are 630 children on Roll an increase of
almost 200 children since 210.
we continue sorry 2010 we continue to be
exceptionally proud of our school and
our pupils and our passion to provide
all of them with the very best is
undiminished
since the school was rebuilt in 1919
1991 following the demolition of the
original 1959 buildings
the governing body and Leadership of the
school have continually looked at ways
to develop the site and Facilities
the additions have included a forest
School a bicycle track music Lodge
Wildlife Area and bird hide a
purpose-built Sports Hall dedicated art
facilities to name just a selection as
well as providing land for the
development of an Essex local
authority-funded children's center to
provide services for local families in
the east of Israeli
we have a wonderful site with attractive
well-maintained buildings and Facilities
one issue we do have however is that
much of Rayleigh suffers and that's that
there is heavy London clay which
inhibits drainage and the result as a
result for the winter months we are
limited in what we're able to do using
our field
we have to carefully manage its use to
ensure that we do not Churn it up
members of the public please do not
um call out or I'll have to ask you to
leave the room thank you sorry Mr Green
no problem
we have to carefully manage its use to
ensure that we do not Churn it up
rendering it unusable often training is
relegated to peripheral areas of the
field or using unsuitable hard surfaces
and many practices and games are forced
to be canceled and we are left
compromising on what we feel we would
like to do or we could achieve
in 2021 we were fortunate to receive a
government funding Grant to replace the
boilers and heating system throughout
our school as a result of a successful
bid
this in turn allowed us the chance to
realize the opportunity to apply for
planning permission to install a
multi-use games area something we'd had
in our asset management plan for a
number of years as an aspirational
project
I've read all of the submissions on the
planning portal and I can categorically
state that this is not a community
project a funded project or a joint
initiative
it's not a commercial Venture in any
sense or indeed a vanity project as one
submission disrespectfully stated
it would be entirely funded by Grovewood
primary school and is intended for the
use of our pupils
this is a resource that we believe will
enhance the provision for the pupils of
our school allowing us more dedicated
teaching space to the sport all year
round
there has been a lot of speculation
about a number of issues including
volume of traffic weekend noise the
insulation of floodlights extending use
beyond that which I've already spoken
but all of this is merely conjecture
I've stressed all of this in
correspondence with local Neighbors when
clarifying the content of the updated
planning submission and I have welcomed
the opportunity to speak either face to
face or on the phone with those
neighbors who have contacted me to
discuss the plans as well as responding
to all questions raised via email
from the initial conception of the idea
and submission of our application to
install the artificial pitch we have
always viewed it as a like-for-like
all-weather alternative that would
enable the pupils at Grovewood school to
make the very best use of the outdoor
space available to them and extend the
range and opportunities of sports that
both boys and girls can access through
the year something that's been widely
promoted and encouraged by policy makers
and sports campaigners alike
our submission proposes no material
change of use or intensification of use
which would add to the issue of user
noise that would affect local residents
and there has never been any intention
of installing artificial lighting to be
used in conjunction with activities on
the muga
as such we were therefore more than
happy to agree to restrictions and
conditions being placed within the
Planning Commission as this was only
ever Our intention
having carefully considered submissions
on the council website we have discussed
with council members that we have
already begun and intend to continue to
plant significant numbers of additional
screening Hedges and trees around our
field for shade and aesthetic purposes
these internal Aid in privacy drainage
and noise reduction as well as
positively offsetting any environmental
impact caused by the replacement of the
grass should our application be
successful
I'd like to thank you for the
opportunity provided to me tonight to
share the background rationale and scope
of the provis proposed application which
we believe would significantly enhance
the sporting opportunities for the
pupils of Grovewood primary
produce thank you Mr Green
the cart we have is Miss balding
I am on who's speaking on this item is
building our she's objecting to this
thank you again miss boarding
you have five minutes and I will
interrupt you at four sorry thank you
good evening I'm Don balding I'm a
resident and I'm representing 170
residents who have signed a petition we
are the parents the grandparents and
supporters of this school and we
strongly object to this application
thank you councilor Jordan and radio
Town Council for seeking due diligence
and for offering support to seek a grant
for appropriate drainage so the school
can maintain a natural grass field for
all of its activities surprisingly this
was refused by the applicant the
applicant still wants to spend over 185
000 pounds on plastic grass these are
challenging times we believe this is a
want and not a need
plastic grass is headline news we thank
the government for its recent moves to
ban plastic grass and planning
applications and the ban of single-use
plastics from October we quote the
environment secretary we all know the
absolute devastating impacts that
plaster can have in our environment and
Wildlife we will continue our Vital work
to protect the environment for future
Generations
the Chelsea flower show has banned
plastic grass professional footballers
refuse to play on it and the fa has
banned it in the Premier League to
prevent long-term serious injuries this
is Green Belt site rocha's own Green
Belt study in 2020 specifically States
this playing field as contributing to
purpose one keeping a natural grass
boundary this will cover nearly half of
the playing field with plastic grass and
a three meter high cage this is covering
2 600 square meters that's more than two
Olympic-sized swimming pools with
plastic
grass helps produce the oxygen we
breathe this is covering over the lungs
of our community
rochford's sustainability strategy is to
reduce the carbon footprint plastic
grass increases this improve air quality
particularly for our schools promote the
benefits of the natural environment to
schools and make behavioral changes
encouraging schools to become Eco
schools
quoting counselor Whitten climate change
affects us all but we also have the
power to do something about it
the applicant is using a low-grade
plastic grass this causes microplastic
pollution and injuries it breaks up it
gets in our lungs in our water systems
in our birds and animals plastic grass
needs chemical cleaning we are deeply
concerned what impact this is going to
have
the reason for this application is and I
quote the existing grass area proposed
for the new mugger does get muddy in the
winter
the applicant's own technical report
says that any excess water will pond on
the field
the school and residents are high risk
areas for surface water flooding we have
serious concerns this will create
problems for the school and our local
properties
I'm sure that everyone is aware of the
increased noise and disturbance the
fencing surrounding a plastic pitch
makes the national planning policy
framework says planning decisions should
aim to avoid noise adversity impacting
on health and the quality of life
sport England says it is important that
disturbance to neighbors should be
carefully considered and the most
significant noise being voice and hockey
impact noises the balls hitting on the
backboards and on the cages
these case officer's report says the
immunity of Residential Properties needs
to be protected and they are in close
proximity
bringing all of these activities
together in one area will intensify the
noise for residents
regarding the fitzwimac application
noise was one of the main reasons for
refusal I quote the planning committee
The Proposal would generate unacceptable
noise pollution detrimental to the
immunity of Me by Resident residential
occupiers
the government inspector agreed the fits
Walmart application was 60 meters away
Grove is eight
we understand the planning process is
not political
however you have one minute to go thank
you would counselors have unfairly
divided a community for no reason
in summary a fair determination can only
be used and based on information
provided from experts which you don't
have ready Town Council objected for
lack of information Sports England
objected twice through lack of
information you don't have a complete
flood report you do not have an
Acoustics report you don't have an
agricultural report you don't have a
biodiversity report this will impact
residents lives and our environment we
love where we live this is a Greenbelt
site please do not cover it in plastic
please do not make a decision without
your due diligence please refuse this
application thank you chair thank you
very much
[Music]
thank you
well I'm going to ask the visiting
members if any of them would like to
speak I know councilor Waters indicated
um
is there anyone else would like
visiting your committee
councilor Lambeau
where sorry yes it's Council Hawaii
and councilor Wilson
this is Wilson yeah okay
councilor Ward can you come up please
you'll have five minutes again I will
ask you uh We'll advise you you've got
four minutes when you've got four
minutes you'll have a minute to go thank
you
thank you chairman and members
this has been a very difficult
application in as much as it has caused
a divide
with the residents of lodgewood in which
this application sits
as one of the ward councilors I've
always needed to be cognizant of all the
sides in this dispute are in any dispute
as I was originally asked to make
representations to the school regarding
the immediate impact this mugger would
have on the surrounding residence
the original specifications that have
become public were not I came to
understand the school's original
intention
but an insertion of potential usage by a
well-intentioned but overzealous agent
a letter was sent out to negate the
impression that the mugger would be
hired out for extended use outside of
its current usage
a promise the Headmaster gave me at the
time of our first meeting to discuss
residence concerns
unfortunately the surrounding residents
were somewhat cynical regarding this
letter and their headmaster's promise
feeling there was still cause for
concern which I fully appreciate
I was also now being contacted by other
residents who were anxious for this
application to go through
I explained to those residents who
wanted this mugger that the surrounding
residents felt they were being unfairly
impacted and I have to say most all of
those residents replied that they fully
understood the impacted residence
concerns
and agreed planning conditions needed to
be put in place to ensure there would be
no material change of use
so
I welcome this report in its entirety as
I believe it satisfactorily deals with
all the issues that have been raised by
concerned residents on both sides over
the last few months
I would also like to personally thank
the planning officer R will Evans for
his diligence and time taken with many
conversations being had regarding this
application
chairman members of the planning
committee I can say no more but leave
this application and its determination
in your capable hands after hearing all
the various people speak thank you thank
you Council so old I'll go to the next
um board member councilor Lamborn please
can Council Lambert you'll have five
minutes and I'll tell you when you have
your views four minutes thank you
Madam chair committee members thank you
for allowing me to speak on this item
as a wall councilor for Lodge Ward on
the council and a town
councilor on the rtc's planning
committee I have been following this
application closely
I don't intend spending too much of your
time
as a lot of the detail has already been
mentioned but
I would like to point out there are
significant outcome questions that have
been left within this application
the officer has inserted open conditions
in relation to soft Landscaping drainage
and maintenance all of which require the
applicant to present detailed plans that
will require approval
drainage is the one item that I believe
cannot be left as a condition requiring
future approval this should be defined
now and agreed by the committee as part
of your deliberations this evening which
obviously it can't
the open drainage issues are not
only if it not only affect the field
area itself but the surrounding
properties
Gardens have have in the past been
flooded in the case of exceptional rain
events
later in the report the office that
describes in detail the layout of the
field and the current drainage but the
console t eec
ECC and has asked that the conditions
are be met before the application can go
ahead
added as a conditions to the application
I'll now move on to noise
I welcome the edition of
um and usage limitations but I am
concerned that the modeling done has
covered usage has not covered usage for
hockey for instance which creates a
different noise profile to the football
or netball it is acknowledged that the
noise levels are already close to or
over acceptable levels
we need a full assessment to model the
different types of noise
in conclusion before reaching
before reaching your daily your decision
this evening I would ask that you defer
this
until the additional information is made
available thank you thank you councilman
yeah Mrs Wilson please sorry I've come
closer sorry
been looking
okay
you'll have five minutes and I'll let
you know when it's for thank you
[Music]
thank you madam chair and thank you
committee members
I object to this planning application on
the following grounds
Essex County Council Suds the
sustainable Drainage Systems report of
the 30th of December 2022
states that they do not object to this
application provides certain conditions
are put in place
if this application does gain approval I
ask that these conditions are indeed put
in place to ensure that measures are
taken to avoid future flooding
particularly as discussed here to today
I have concerns that this change to
surface conditions will enhance the risk
of flooding due to the draining issue on
this site as care needs to be taken that
water during Heavy Rain does not soak
into neighboring properties
for your information Grovewood Academy
declined directly Town councils offered
to improve drainage
there is still no noise assessment nor
is there a biodiversity assessment as
requested by Bradley Town Council
now with regard to the nature
conservation there is much evidence
against the use of AstroTurf
evidence specifically from the UK I have
taken studies from Plymouth University
which have shown that natural grasses as
we know home for beetles worms insects
Etc attracting birds that feed on these
insects
natural grass also absorbs sound and
reduces noise pollution
natural grass improves quality improves
water quality and prevent the soil
erosion
natural grafts like all living plants
takes up carbon dioxide and releases
oxygen as we all know
so why take this away and replace with
plastic
as a council we are not given a good
example by supporting the green light by
supporting the green agenda by replacing
our natural green with plastic green
Plymouth University also states that
artificial grass can make its way into
the soil in the form of microplastic
pollution
we all know we need to reduce our
plastic use not increase it by by
damaging our environment further
artificial grass does not provide any
food for living creatures
artificial grass reaches significantly
greater temperatures than those reached
by natural grass
artificial grass can overheat in hot
weather making it unusable for use
evidence shows that environmental issues
from choosing to put down artificial
grass far outweighs any benefits
so I ask why are we covering our green
belt with plastic
we are destroying natural land to enable
Sports to be played in winter
surely effective drainage is a solution
not covering good land in plastic
whilst this is going to be a Maltese or
is proposed to be a multi-sports piece
of land there is no significant
shortfall of football pitches in the
Rainy area there are other sporting
pictures available as well
I'd just like to note that there are
other sports that can be played in the
winter muddy months if necessary
Sports England refused twice to approve
due to minimal information being
provided as to why the perfectly
acceptable natural Turf pictures needed
to be removed in order for children to
play more Sports
I ask that you declined this application
on environmental grounds and that of
further destruction to our natural land
you have one minute left thank you I
asked I'll go faster
um I asked the drainage issues are
sorted to resolve the sporting issue and
allow natural glass uh natural grass to
be played upon
finally I refer you to paragraph 10 the
final paragraph in your report where
Amanda Bleak the inspect the inspector
said for reasons given above and taking
matters into account I conclude that the
development would be contrary to the
relevant policies of the council's local
plan and therefore the appeal should be
dismissed thank you for your time
thank you Art thank you very much
counselor hi please
again Council Ohio you've got five
minutes you know you know this you know
it
thank you chairman
um I'll start off by saying that we've
got a good audience here tonight and I
want to make it clear that
this committee is for when we disagree
with officers and that's the whole point
of the committee
we are allowed to disagree with them
um I won't repeat too much of what has
been said what was that what was that
Barbed comment for I don't know it
wasn't a Bible point it was just to say
that well we know how to conduct
ourselves yes committee um we can either
this is my I'm allowed to speak and I
will stop the pull up but I just
wondered what your comment actually
meant because I had a few reasons it
meant that I can disagree with an
officer but there's nothing to be made
from that we're allowed to disagree
thank you very much yeah and I want to
make that clear
thank you very much
um first of all I'll want to comment
comment about the green belt this is
not a change of use we've been advised
however there's is a change of structure
there's a three meter high fence going
in
that itself needs planning permission
within the green belt
there is a lot of
words in the report about it it's not
affecting the openness too much but I
would disagree with that and I think
it's a an important point we should all
remember on the committee
I'd also come back to the fence in a few
minutes when I'm talking about noise
um
I'll now move on to surface water
drainage which has been mentioned by a
number of people already
the report says a detailed surface water
drainage scheme
is to be signed to be to be designed
after approval
I will Echo speakers tonight where I'll
say that I think that's wrong we should
have the detail surface water drainage
scheme
designed prior to approval not after
approval
um as we understand the other report
says there's possible Pauling on the
ground at the moment and
the understanding I have speaking to
residencies that runs into their Gardens
there's no reason to think this would be
any different in fact the the runoff I
think is the same as it under the
proposal is the same as it would be now
um to move on to
noise
Mr Evans has said that this isn't a
change of use however I'm pointing out
that there is a fence going in which is
three meters higher and which is metal
there is no assessment
made
of the noise in relation to that fence
and I think that needs to be done as
well as that there's a synthetic playing
surface which is noisier than grass
and the the noise element is not just
around people the first one I want one
which might people have spoken about was
about people it was much later but
however there is a certainly a changing
working practices with people working
from home now which noise would affect
whereas perhaps in the past it wouldn't
have done the um the fence old ladies
designed to stop and rebound balls this
is going to be noisy and there's no
assessment made of it at all in the
report and I think that should be taken
into account
um
I will just go back very briefly to the
the green belt I just say that um
Mr Evans in his statement
said that the area to the left on our
screen will be kept open
that suggests to me that the area we're
talking about isn't being kept open and
therefore we're not retaining the
openness of the green belt that we
should do
that is all I'm saying I think the
committee should move for deferral for
updates on those three points thank you
thank you very much Council
members before we actually debate this
I'm I've been asked if we could actually
introduce ourselves for the recording
because as you can see we haven't got
any name plates with a slight an error
but can I just ask for the recording
that we go around the table and just
introduce us and I will ask our officers
to do the same so it's only recorded I'm
councilor Lauren Shaw the chairman of
this committee
cancel it and you left the vice chair of
councilor Mike Webb hawkwell East
councilor Mike Steptoe wrote South
councilor constable ashington and
Hockley
Council dose bearing Trinity Ward
councilor Leslie butcher Hawk walist
councilor Tracy Knight holbridge
councilor Chris Staley Dan Hall and
roriff
Council of Jim Crips Down Home North
councilor Jack Lawman Wheatley Ward
councilor Asia news Hockley board
thank you councilor Mrs Christie Mason
hawkwell West Russia District residents
thank you
Katie Rogers team leader in development
management
out of 11's senior planning officer
Katie Fowler senior planning officer
if I'm done planning manager
[Music]
Phil drain director of place
Sonia Worthington principal Democratic
and Corporate Services officer
education does anyone want to speak
please can you indicate oh councilor
Lawman
counselor grits
Christy Mason
I'm not running
not right now standing right
Council Norman you have five minutes
please
chairman uh
from my own experiences of these mother
although they've been a lot smaller in
AstroTurf I'll therefore put my views
across and that is so I wasn't really
aware of this it's not my area so I
picked up this evening to all the
arguments
the first question I have is is fencing
it why is is there questions involved in
my discussion is why are we having the
fence in at all because if it's that
distance as I'm looking at the map from
the housing and they've got long Gardens
how many youngsters got to kick a board
it's going to go over three meter thing
let's go that far distance to end up in
someone's Garden
um and I questioned it why is there a
need for it just seems to be a bit of an
over development but also it's um I come
to the health and safety side of this a
little bit because we're talking about
AstroTurf I'm fully aware how it works
and it can be quite slippery so we're
talking about putting youngsters in bad
weather on there because it's the the
mud and grass whereas when you play
football you can do a sliding tackle you
can run up and you can do all sorts of
things the first thing I see here is
youngsters running into because they
will get a speedo they run into that
thing so they can cause theirselves
damage secondly if they was to either
impact that ground on a sliding tackle
or or otherwise and then get injured on
that because it's a hard surface I'll
take that a little further they then
talk about further on they want to pour
a Curtain divide in these pitches well
that again is another trap for children
to run into and when you when they're
gained up in sport they're not thinking
they're running I'm not a football fan I
don't I couldn't even tell you a
football I could I suppose but I don't
watch football but at the same time but
they could also link to other uses I
mean other sports I mean such as rugby
what happens if they want to run a rugby
team and they put well we've got a bit
of Astra Turf out here someone's going
to get a nasty injury so I'm concerned
about the health and safety so one was
the question what's the difference
between net and grass what the
difference is if you fall over in a
muddy field it's all right you get a bit
dirty your mum has a go you know you go
in the shower you share a bath with a
dozen blows and it's okay but if you
fall on this stuff you're in trouble so
and I I really question that the need
for this at all it looks like an attack
on the amenities for the people living
nearby they're going to be looking over
a two meter fence to a three meter fence
ceiling packed on their vision
it then also got this big green thing
but um and then of course there's the
health and safety issues and I just
think it's an over development it's a
huge great thing I can't see the need
for defensive at all because the size of
the two pitches
um so I question it and I I just feel as
I can't support this application
unfortunately I think it's an over
development and it impacts on the
immunity of the local people thank you
chairman thank you
oh well would you like to come back
regarding
um why the fence is going to be
installed please so that was the
question
why do we need a face
yeah
well from a planning office perspective
the role of the planning authorities and
to ask why we're there to judge the
application it's Merit so I don't
recognize that question why but as it's
been asked the reason for it is
operationally that obviously the way
that muggers work
um you know there's the rebound system
isn't it really so it does save someone
running a lot of uh of the guards to to
go and get the ball so it's to contain
that sport within that defined area I
think that's the best answer that I can
give okay thank you
not scripts please
you're not on counselor hello yep you
are now
thank you madam chairman members
I'm not going to duplicate what's
already been said I try not to anyway
it's a very wide-ranging report most
aspects have been covered the one I want
to speak about is the absence of
statutory drainage
assessments signed off by the
appropriate authorities
um point eight in the recommendations
and point nine in the recommendations I
asked for two uh joins assessments to be
signed off by the lead local flood
Authority
the other one the third one the nine one
have actually has to be signed off by
the
Watford District Council the LPA the
local Planning Association
so there's three documents there that
are missing at the moment I think
they're critical
because as the officers pointed out this
sits in a low it does puddle it's also
in what's called a critical drainage
area
so I think there's every reason why if I
go back to the officers report in his
recommendations seven eight and nine he
makes the point that no work will
commence until such time as that report
has been approved and signed off
so there is no progress to be made in
pushing this through
pre-approving it until we've got that
information it's not holding up anything
and I believe we should have those
reports before we make a decision on
this and I think that's reflected in
what other people have said as well
thank you thank you
would you like to come back thank you I
would like to come back on that so
I've noted that Council lambon stated
made a statement at 4.3 it does clearly
State a no objection from the lead local
flood Authority I would like to set this
case in context if I may
there's an application
22008 or 3 for large industrial scale
developments schemes I've been dealing
with the aviation way the
recommendation of imposition of
conditions to this effect so what we've
had is we've had a technical document
submitted by the applicants it's got a
detailed technical documents
um
that was submitted so what I'm trying to
say is is that it's not unusual so it's
standard practice to condition in line
with planning practice a number of these
conditions so basically what the an
objection letter received from the Lee
local flood Authority actually indicates
that following reading of the technical
document
and following
um the submission of that plan that you
have in front of you there that there is
no objection to the principle because
basically what we do have to consider as
planners and as decision makers is
there's one very simple question we have
to ask ourselves isn't there does this
development make matters any worse what
I would say is from visiting the site
and knowing and reading the documents
I've read There are documents that have
been submitted regarding flooding
so and what I'd say is this this site is
a victim of its own position it's not
the perpetrator flooding it's a victim
of flooding coming from Land above at
Warwick green and the land actually as I
said in my report runs from
South West to Northeast which means that
water runs away from the direction of
the cycle track and the rear aspects of
the Gardens at Clarence Road so the only
PR the only property that would be
affected by flooding of water pooling
would be the school itself and also what
I would say is that this drainage system
for this actual
all weather page would actually
alleviate an existing problem but just
coming back to the question I paused in
the beginning is does this development
make matters any worse on-site within
the vicinity the answer is no it doesn't
so just to confirm that the three
conditions they are discharge of
condition applications which is a fairly
standard methodology of dealing with
this which means they are happy with
with the information such that we can
come to the conclusion that there'll be
no harm however
the the greater detail is required just
for signing off so and that's just a
standard way of working that that we
apply those conditions in many different
um development proposals many of them
are massive major infrastructure Works
where the possibility of flooding is far
greater than this site
thank you
yes it is yeah right good
um
firstly I'd like to say we've heard from
various speakers and there's obviously a
very difficult balance here we've heard
the passion of the Headmaster wanting to
provide what he sees as an appropriate
sporting facility for his pupils and
we've heard of the concerns of the
people around
we have a problem because we have to
balance up those two opposing views and
come which with hopefully a sensible
decision
first thing I'm going to turn to the
conditions which I have that are
proposed should this proposal be
approved and I'm concerned at some
emissions
conditions three limitation of use
there's no times there's no days they're
in the report they're not in the
condition I'm sure the officers can
redress that should this committee
decide to
approved
and I'm afraid I'm going to comment
again on the flooding
the flooding in seven eight and nine I
appreciate and I've heard the officer's
comments and I've got no problem with
that I do have a problem when it says in
each one to be approved by the local
planning Authority
this Authority does not have a flooding
expert we have asked in the past and we
are told that we are wholly reliant on
Essex County Council
so I'm rather concerned that we're
putting in a condition that says that
the planning authorities got to approve
it when we haven't got the expertise to
do so
the other
areas that are not in the conditions
that I'd like to bring attention to
is the noise aspect which I don't think
has been covered
um adequately and I must admit I'm a
little bit concerned uh confused about
the distance but I'm sure the officer
can clarify that for me
but there seems to be more outstanding
than there more questions than answers
at the moment the one thing that really
concerns me is the use of plastic over
green belt
the European chemical Authority
states there is a risk to the
environment
it says risk to the violently using
microplastics in products including the
infill for artificial football pitches
now I'm not an expert I don't know what
exactly the material is proposed here
but we have here it is we should
decrease exposure to harmful chemicals
and minimize any possible risk the
agency recommends basic hygiene methods
I think we've all had this email
wash your hands after playing on the
field and before eating
quickly clean any cuts and scrapes take
off your shoes sports equipment to
prevent tracking granules into your
house
if you get rubber granules in your mouth
do not swallow them
I don't know how significant that is
and it's not from my reading it's not
covered in the report and I do think
that the questions that have been raised
we should at least defer this report if
not refuse it because that to me if this
is right and every member on this
committee has had this email
then with that information I think
that's quite significant because we're
talking about health and safety by
encouraging physical activity and now we
talk about health and safety and with
potentially if this is correct putting
Children at Risk
so my concerns I'd like to see
alleviated and the other concerns that
I've raised thank you thank you Council
Mason
counselor I'm sorry
oh well would you like to respond please
sorry there is on the issue of flooding
so council Mrs Mason has raised a good
point so in terms of discharge of these
conditions what is important to
emphasize we recognize that we're not
expert in uh flood and drainage so so
basically on those three conditions
which is the conditions
seven eight and nine what we do is when
we get an application submitting further
details as this should discharge of
conditions application so it's not a
planning application but in the same
manner that we sought the advice of the
lead local flood Authority in connection
with this application we wouldn't attach
ourselves from the same process so we
would on though that application so an
application I assume would come in for
the discharge of those three conditions
together it would make sense that way we
as a council would formally consult the
llfa the lead local flood authorities
say this is the information that now has
been submitted subsequent to the
conditions that were placed upon your
earlier recommendation and it's a formal
procedure that we would not discharge
those conditions until we have written
approval and confirmation for from the
lead local flood Authority that it has
considered that information as part of
the disjudication application and it's
not unusual for us as planners to say a
present a presence we can't discharge it
because the lead local flood Authority
has further information or further
clarification so it is actually quite a
rigorous process of actually just
because we've included these conditions
it does mean that we do follow through
and strike through on on these
requirements so we would be relying and
using as a formal process the llfa to
advise us as to whether those conditions
could be discharged thank you very much
I've now got cancer Stanley thank you
have you got microphone yet
John hello
uh thank you chairman
um there are several factors here one
that I've got to remind the officer of
4.3 on 6.26
uh Angry and Walter no objection it says
having reviewed the documents which
accompanied the planning application we
would recommend the issuing of a holding
objection on the basis of the following
information does the information does
not allow us to assess the flood risk
development so let us get that quite
clear it's a holding objection and not
no objection
thank you also I'd like to point out
that
Plastics in any carpet causes burns when
you fall over
and to prove that you could ask my son
because he fell down the stairs or a
plastic carpet and he got burns on his
arms when he fell so
this is a a bad case that's going
forward with the children because
they're always falling over however
minute I've just had it pointed out what
you read out that there was a holding
objection the next little paragraph says
issued a no objection letter on the 30th
of December recommending three
conditions be attached to the planning
permission if minded granting planning
permission so there was a little bit
add-on that you missed okay thank you
for pointing that I've just I've just
had that pointed out so thank you thank
you but it does say a holding a holding
conjunction reading to the next yes the
words that were printed are says a
holding objection that's all I want you
to put forward
um having said this about the turf from
what I understand is that water has to
be applied to the turf when playing on
it as you would have noticed in the
European games and hockey and what have
you
um it's usually full of water
and that's how it works when you fall
over you don't actually fall on the
grass because it's dry you fall on water
I think you'll find that most football
pitches are full of water as well you
could tell that by the pace of the bowl
um when it from one end to the of the
field to the other so if you look at the
football there are there is water on the
pitches and and that is recirculated
from a pump back onto the field through
the through the membrane and back into
the pump and the reservoir so there is
no water allowed or isn't as being put
in the application to water the plastic
field also I'm a bit concerned about the
attenuation now if the attenuation tank
is holding water or dispersing water
from the original buildings
will there be enough attenuation to hold
the water that will be on this playing
field and that's coming out for the
offer the uh French drains
I don't believe so and I do believe that
we it needs to be clarified a little bit
further in the way of holding water in
attenuation tanks
plus the fact that there is a 40
millimeter
liar of McAdam and from what I
understand McAdam is on the roads and
they don't hold water that's the reason
why we've got drains so
how is the water going to get through
the talm academy
that has been laid of 40 millimeters of
it to get to the substrand of the pitch
to use the French drains perhaps the
officers could let me know how that
works please thank you thank you very
much
I've shown to members the surfacing I'm
not an expert in surfacing but I I do
sort of see what the point the
constantly is making
what I would like to point towards is
can we go back to the previous slide
please so Council Stanley has raised the
issue about sort of controlling the flow
of water so
in terms of the controlling the floor
there's a floor control valve here so
the idea is that it's
it's working to model of a 1 in 30 uh
um flood event so in terms of the
technical documents that the applicant
has produced what the lead local flood
Authority is satisfied can be achieved
is
the
control of surface water runoff to
account for a 1 in 30 year event of
flooding and as I understand from the
representations received there is one
representation that's accounted for the
report that says that this site is only
flooded once in once in a blue moon so
the one what I'm trying to demonstrate
is that the one in 30-year flood event
is that this
schematic scheme has accounted for that
now in terms of them Academy don't
actually have an answer to that because
I'm not an expert I'm only sharing with
vendors what's been submitted and also
the lead local flood Authority would
have had sight of that surface drainage
treatment and they haven't raised any
comment in relation to concerns that the
water wouldn't percolate through them
according to the bedroots through the
um the hard core to the drainage pipes
below so
from our perspective as officers
that there is no questions that are left
unanswered in that respect
thank you chairman for giving me a
second bite
um I think that uh we need to
find out if that substrate that we're
we're talking about in The talm Academy
is the right thing to use
from that perspective of finding out a
lot more about astro turf where you
would actually have water on AstroTurf
to keep it Supple and and not to get
burns from it there are a lot of
questions there that we've everyone has
raised and I like to put this to the
committee that we should defer this item
with reference to the questions that
have been asked thank you
all right members um we've got a motion
on the table for deferment can I have a
show of hands to agree to
um
right what other I've just been what are
your actual reasons for deferment please
Council standing we need to have them
exactly
okay
um one is the drainage system the
as it stands at the moment
also the uh
astro turf itself how safe is that
the
fence in that's going around the
perimeter is that necessary as it wasn't
before
the attenuation if there's any more
attenuation tanks to be put in
because I don't believe a valve can do
that we've had floods since 19 since
2015 and we've had five floods since
then so I don't see that as being one in
30 years I I gather that I mean can you
just do your reasons sorry sorry sorry
not um
so we need the officers need to know
exactly what your deferrals are so they
can be written down thank you
recommendations seven eight and nine
that's the assessment on on the uh not
only the environment but also on the
flood uh question
um
yeah I think that covers near enough
covers everything right
yeah
yeah I've got counselor he's uh wanted
to speak but you're talking uh for
another reason for deferment yes I think
we should also ask for a full noise
assessment right that's what councilor
this is exactly what I was going to
actually uh propose but also I'd like to
see some of the things that have been
asked for by some of the contributors
tonight one of the things is
biodiversity report
um
I'm not sure why but someone mentioned
an agricultural report is there a reason
being why there would be an agricultural
report written needed for this I don't I
don't actually see it but it actually
was mentioned earlier on
yes they obviously want to hear me
um to reasons to deferment I would like
the clarification of the times and days
in the conditions which isn't there and
it's slightly confusing in the report so
just some clarification so that the
school and we are well aware that what
the hours of use
and also the
Headmaster mentioned that they were
providing a planting scheme to alleviate
the noise and to soften I presume it
would do anyway and to soften the
boundary and perhaps that could be
considered looked at in the conditions
as well a planting scheme
thank you
[Music]
my point on the noise report can we make
sure it covers the fence as well
especially because that's something
that's going to be a new
and that might make a difference
are you clear of what um the reasons for
deferment are please
the Landscaping is covered at condition
six
there was a plan that I showed you
earlier whether it showed some tree
planting in that Crescent area if we go
back a few slides so the actual in terms
of details of the Landscaping it's
included at condition six I'm not sure
whether
council Mrs Mason was saying that was
absent and she needed for the
clarification but it's covered at
condition six
can be removed could I just say one
thing about the assessments and this is
very important I feel
it was covered the assessments was
covered in a part of my report
so
in terms of aborticultural reporters so
obviously
for development is to affect the root
protection area of trees you're looking
at the the types of trees the proximity
of trees to the area of excavation now
I showed you a plan for example where
there were trees in this area here
so so this mocha area is nowhere near
any tree
so what I would say is is that in terms
of an arboricultural assessment what
exactly would we be assessing the trees
are nowhere near the application site
and you're scraping off to 300 mL of
topsoil at a location
43 meters away from trees and ecology
required it's a more lawn so in terms of
it was long grass I would have we would
have advised of a preliminary ecological
assessment but
really in terms of ecology you have got
to ask yourself in terms of the
triggering mechanisms to require
assessments it's the same for an FRA the
site isn't one hectare in size it's not
a major development it doesn't trigger
the necessary it doesn't uh trigger
those requirements
um but in terms of the acoustic you know
I'm not commenting on that because that
that is the point that's raised by
members
but the aborig cultural is I think we've
got to consider is is there an actual
valid reason to require it to be the
case and I did clarify this uh I was
just a mention that councilor Eaves
asked he thought he was uh mentioned and
he didn't know why and you've explained
that it's fine I've just got to say to
what um Miss balding I'm sorry you can't
speak at this point I'm sorry you've had
the five abilities just for the
committee I do apologize on that behalf
members we've had um
reasons for you to develop to for
deferral can I have a vote on this
motion for deferral please can I have a
raise of hands and keep them raised
until Sonia lets me know
thank you
members that's unanimous this item six
is has been
has been deferred until the reports are
available thank you very much members
I'm going to stop this meeting now for
five to ten minutes so the residents on
who were here for Grove Road can a
surrey Grove Wood School can go and then
it won't disrupt um the rest of the
meeting thank you very much
yeah yeah I've gotta leave
recording
is that better
[Music]
members let's come back in please we'd
like to get the meeting started
do you members of the public if you'd
like to be seated if you're staying
[Music]
rumors of the public if you'd like to be
seated if you're staying in and members
can you please come back to the
committee table so we can get started to
real
running quite late
all right
I have no idea
after the presentation
left and she's staying outside staying
outside I'll go and get her at the end
of this afternoon
right members of the public please be
seated members
rights
uh councilor sure has left the room as
she said she was because she's got a
number between
interest uh councilor Steptoe is going
to help me with be my vice chairman for
this one if that's okay
got to come round yes we're useful you
can see everybody
writing an agenda item eight
c2-00962-adv land east of ashington Road
and North of Oxford Garden Way
Katie Rogers will present the officer's
report
Casey
can you hear me yeah that's working
um thank you Katie could you please just
zoom in to the top right hand corner of
that plan thank you
so members this is an application for an
advertisement it's a freestanding V
board type advert so you can see em it's
pole mounted so the poles are to a
maximum height of approximately 4.25
meters with a sign signage board here to
a height of about three meters
the depth across this side here is about
1.5 meters and you can see on this image
here it would be two-sided in like a
v-shape formation
if you can just then pan across please
to the
and down to the bottom
thank you
so the advert would be positioned in
front of what was number one five one
fifty ashington Road and you can see
that the advert would be set back from
the footway along ashendum Road and also
set back from the footway that will be
implemented to the new access that will
go into the site of ashendum Road
advert applications must be determined
in relation to two matters and it's set
out in the report that these are the
impact on amenity and on public safety
and the officer's report goes into some
detail in relation to these two aspects
but in terms of both of these the
application tonight is considered
acceptable
the application would not be illuminated
and it would not obstruct visibility
splays so officers have gone back and
you can see in the report gone back to
the county highways Authority and we're
satisfied that in this position here it
would not obstruct forward visibility or
indeed visibility coming out of this
approved Junction once formed
however a condition is recommended such
that the advert would have to be removed
in any case once this vehicular access
which is the approved one into the site
is completed and in use for with for
vehicle traffic so that would eliminate
eliminate any concern about
pedestrians Crossing at this point here
and the advert impeding their visibility
as they look north um just should check
whether any traffic was coming because
once this
um pink hatched area is in use for
vehicle traffic and pedestrians were
using the Footwear around this corner
and then Crossing at this point here
this advert will be required to be
removed by that condition that's
recommended
so the application is therefore
recommended for approval subject to the
conditions are stated in the report
right then
old members councilor Foster isn't here
Council Shaw's left the room so that
leaves councilor Watton if you'd like to
come up
now this one probably speak water or
softer
sorry cancel Wilson uh Christine Austin
speaks first
Christina seems like to come up
yeah
got five minutes and I'll interrupt you
for let you know you've got a minute
left to speak
foreign
we're all distracted to a point when
driving whether listening to the radio
or just thinking this is a this is a
fact but either way our mind is
distracted traffic on the ashington road
is often horrendous causing anxiety
about being late for work or
appointments
something catches your eye a flashy new
advertising billboard saying coming soon
it almost shouts at you what is coming
soon you are intrigued and you want to
read on what's a harm it only takes a
second crash as quickly as that because
you weren't fully focused on the road
the billboard that you were reading
advertising the blood development
opposite two schools has been designed
very purposefully to distract your
attention from everything else you
should be doing for a moment in time the
sign that passive did its job in that
one second of distraction caused by
reading that billboard a child could
step into the road a good driver won't
be distracted by a billboard designed to
distract them will they but are all
drivers good drivers definitely not
should we risk an additional distraction
at this very location where there has
been four accidents in one week one a
write-off needing Hospital attendance in
the entire history of ashington Road
there has never been four acts accidents
in one week well certainly not before
blah moved in
the risks of distracting drivers at this
location are not hypothetical drivers
jump the lights here often so is it wise
to erect a large piece of advertising
here would it make a difference to Road
Safety if Road Safety here is already a
concern well yes it would make a
difference so no it's not wise law
naturally will counter here that the
location is already dangerous and their
new Junction will be better and safer
fantasy the bottom line is motorists
take risks because they are sick of
sitting in traffic jams day on day the
development is just adding to the volume
of certainly not improving things that
speculation and computer modeling not
real life let's face it they said the
satanic was Unsinkable professed to be
the safest ship in the world that was
until reality happened
an article in ad week 2018 highlights an
advertising company created a sign that
tailors its advertisements based on the
speed of traffic that is static
acceptance that adverts on the roadside
are designed to Target drivers this
article tells us that advertising
Billboards are designed to grab
attention from a driver for a short
period of time and convey information to
them we must recognize that in certain
situations such as when driving past the
school drivers should apply all of their
attention to driving because when all
are part of one's attention is on
reading an advert one cannot be paying
full attention to the road
a crash when traveling at a modded speed
is set unavoidably in motion not at the
precise time the crash occurs but at the
point when the action to avoid it needs
to be taken and wasn't you might hit
another car or object but outside of
school it could be a child or multiple
children
let's assume that it takes an average
person one second to react to a sudden
obstacle that appears in front of their
car considering they must see the
obstacle recognize it as a problem
decide what to do then do it one second
isn't very long to do all of this
response times differ but if we take one
second as being an average when driving
at 30 miles per hour in two seconds one
second not paying attention to the road
through reading the advert plus one
second to react once seeing the obstacle
a car will travel approximately 27
meters if the driver has chosen to slam
on their brakes to avoid the obstacle
the brake pedal will be applied after
having traveled that distance and
according to the dvla the stopping
distance for a car traveling at 30 miles
per hour is 23 meters before coming to a
stop that car will have traveled
approximately 50 meters
blow mentioned two examples of billboard
advertising which had been approved by
RDC Ross Lane and Hall Road neither
development or opposite two schools with
over five 500 children's 4 to 11 years
old neither site left neither site have
light control progesterone Crossing
opposite the entrance neither site have
an adjacent bus stop and one where the
pulling Lane has been removed neither
site have had half their pavement
removed in fact to the country both
these sites have had Pavements created
where they did not exist before the roar
ethane development being on the edge of
an industrial estate not smack in the
middle of an urbanization they're in no
way are these comparable to what is
being proposed here should we allow
anything that will distract drivers
right outside of school no we should not
we ban adverts on TV for things that
might cause harmful behaviors in
children surely we shouldn't be putting
adverts in locations that increase the
risk to life-changing or life-ending
injuries to them I'm not saying bad
roadside Billboards I'm saying that you
should consider the impact on the
community of poorly located distraction
devices and say no to increasing the
risk at a critical location where many
children are involved experience should
tell you by now that boring here is five
minutes thank you
foreign
[Applause]
do we have any visiting members wishing
to speak
I know Miss Mrs Squires Coleman
who knows so uh Castle Woodson will
sleep first
yes sure this time
thank you chairman and uh good evening
Members First of all I would like to
talk about the overbearing and intrusive
impact of this display board on the
street scene this is a 4.25 meter high
by 1.75 meter wide nearly 14 feet by six
foot uh not the average estate agents
board to be cited in a prominent
position along the very busy ashington
road immediately opposite Junior schools
attended daily by over 500 pupils with
the associated attendance by parents
taking their children to and from school
it will be a distraction additional to
the other General activity going on
around the junction and the busy traffic
light Pelican Crossing in immediate
vicinity for drivers and pedestrians
adding an advertising board would add a
further and unnecessary distraction and
heightened risk factors next if I can
cover concern in relation to Public
Safety particularly distracting to
motorists condition 3A on page 8.1 is
very specific on this point it's says no
advertisement should be cited or
displayed so as to endanger persons
using the highway Railway Waterway dock
harbor or Aerodrome civil or military I
believe that the works going on to
develop the junction were already
causing a distraction and this sign
board will further exacerbate the
problem over the past few weeks we have
seen multiple vehicle provision
collisions and injury accidents at this
precise location of this application
site involving young children two were
on consecutive days I note on page 8.7
paragraph 3.20 that Essex highways
believe it would not be a distraction
because it would not be illuminated nor
sighted within the highway the sign will
by its very nature be visible to drivers
due to its size the developer would not
be placing it there if they believed it
could not be seen by drivers that is the
whole point now if I turn to conditions
condition 5 says any structure or
hoarding erected or used principally for
the purpose of displaying advertisements
should be maintained in a condition that
does not in danger the public given the
application States freestanding post
panel signage in the event of a severe
weather event how can safety be
guaranteed condition 8 is totally
country with condition one and talks
about consent for five years and uses
the reason as pedestrian and Public
Safety there are numerous references in
the reports of the sign being removed
upon their first use
paragraph 3.18 on page 8.7 refers in
terms of conditions and based on recent
observation history law history blur
together with their contractors is not a
company that appears to proactively
respect conditions wheel washing mud on
the road safety in the recent ice
cleaning Etc thus showing respect
and consideration to local residents
that should be disrespected disrespect
no respect I apologize I contest that
most reasonable people or companies
would see conditions as something to
proactively comply with I sense that
Law's policies to knowingly breach
conditions and see if they are
challenged retrospectively either by the
residents or the council's planning
enforcement team as an aside I note in
the officers report in page 8.7
paragraph 3.21 it compares the
application with two other developments
where large signs are in place I can
test that these are not comparable or
relevant to this application as neither
are close to schools a pelican Crossing
and such a complex and challenging
Junction and are therefore a much lower
safety risk therefore in summing up
members you are an experienced and
competent committee here tonight
clearly your decision must be policy
compliant that said policy has to be
applied pragmatically in the context of
the specific detail of the application
before you in this case given the
proposed size being prominent and
overbearing and impacting on the street
scene and which must affect visibility
located near a large Primary School on a
busy road in the close vicinity of a
pelican Crossing and advertisement
display board is by its very nature a
significant distraction and must
therefore negatively impact the
concentration of drivers and the
consequential impact on safety for these
reasons I suggest that there are no
conditions which can be imposed to
sufficiently allay your concerns on
safety and for those reasons I
respectfully ask you to refuse this
application thank you chairman
thank you Council Wilson
[Applause]
councilor Squires Coleman let's come up
you have five minutes and I'll let you
know when there's a minute left yes
thank you chair um I'm the councilor
that covers uh hawkwell East which
um covers the area opposite the proposed
holding
to my understanding the Town and Country
planning
um control of advertising regulations
2007 informs us that all low up for
interpretation considerations can be
given to visual and oral immunity and
the effect of the hoarding will have in
the immediate neighborhood where
residents or passers-by will be aware of
the adverse Testament there has been
some talk this morning or this evening
about the possible dangers
and the technical information having
regarding the possible holding
but over the past few months I had
become aware of the heart stuff those
living and traveling in and the area of
ashinden Road are going to lose so much
over the next few years their open
spaces and maybe a much love tree the
residents of Rochford those that love
their Community those who are very
passionate about their surroundings are
concerned about the visual pollution
this sign will cause
as stated earlier the very purpose of
this hoarding is to be visible from a
distance it's there to stand out
Studies have found that visual pollution
and in this study they include
advertising audience affects the overall
well-being and thus the quality of life
of individuals and communities it
affects the person's ability to enjoy
their environment which isn't considered
no less significant a part of the fabric
of communities as clean water or air and
animal habitat
blue homes will sell their houses
whether there is none or a hundred hosed
ends they will make a very healthy
profit
so I'm asking for the well-being of
local residents to be taken into
consideration for their needs to be met
for their voices for the voices of the
people that we serve to be heard I'm
asking for this application to be
refused thank you
thank you
all right that's through ask if any
committee members wish to speak
what's the web
uh I think councilor Lawman was next
I like them so Council Webb if you'd
like to carry on
holding it is it on
last Wednesday I picked up my children
from Holt Farm School it was very busy
on the pavement as 500 kids and parents
came out
we stopped to look at our magnificent
oak tree a beloved Landmark over 100
years old
we then had to watch out for flying
Stones as the road had not been cleaned
by Bloor as the wheel washing machine
had stopped but the mud encased lorries
still rumbled down the road
fast forward a few years and I'm on the
school run again
as 500 children and parents leave the
school on the now narrowed 1.2 meter
wide pavement rammed together like
sardines choking on the pollution from
the extra traffic without our beloved
oak tree to help fight the pollution my
children asked me
why did the oak tree have to die
who did this to our school
to our community to our environment
I don't have to say a word
um
I'm just points a finger to the large
imposing four meter high sign directly
opposite the school with one word on it
that stands out like some nighttime
vision blur
the sign acts as a daily reminder to our
community over which company Place
profits over people and nature it was
not enough that they ripped down our
tree not enough
can you please get some point the sign
and they need to remind us of who did it
we are watchford not bloford to put a
4.25 meter high and over three three
meter Wide Sign up in the middle of a
residential area where no other signs
are to be found is not in keeping with
the immediate area it will be a huge
distraction for drivers slowing them
down not because they want to buy a
property but because they remain shocked
that blore thought it was a good idea to
put a junction here
in their report 3.7 does not mention
that in the immediate vicinity of this
location our houses not Billboards you
have to go all the way down to Daley's
road to see a billboard and a shop in
One Direction and all the way up to
sapwoods in the other
the surrounding section of road is
residential not a building site like the
two examples given in 3.21
indeed in 3.21 it does not mention any
other development site in the district
that placed a large housing board
billboard opposite a school next next to
a busy and dangerous Crossing area if a
driver's attention is taken in by the
blue board then it's likely one of the
school children will suffer this site is
significantly different to the others
that have been mentioned
I'm told that blower Homes located near
schools
um houses located near schools carry a
higher value because it ensures that the
owner will be able to get their child a
place at the school perhaps this is why
blah we're keen to use this as the
access point and put the sign here
given that the site is not even visible
from this part of the ashington road
could the sign lot simply be located
further away from this busiest of
locations
but law suggests it will be a five-star
setup due to the decision to allow
construction vehicles to access the
front of the development Vigilant
residents have already seen a number of
incidents over the last few weeks that
have been a significant distraction from
motorists these include a reversing
Lorry clipping the railings and hitting
a wheel away please on this on the sign
cars being hit by lorries and also the
difficulties that vehicles have had with
them the mud and the stones on the road
as a representative for a representative
of the community we have had enough of
plot imposing themselves on us yet they
want a daily reminders of what they did
with this four meter high signage the
sign is not in keeping with the area no
other Billboards are to be found in this
area and it will be a significant
distraction for motorists no other part
of the district has a billboard up
opposite of school and I believe this is
a significant issue of safety that we
need to address as a committee
it cannot be permitted to go ahead thank
you thank you
[Applause]
yeah members of the public there's uh
filming at the back if you'd like to
come forward please and take a seat at
the front you get better filming we
don't mind you filming but we like to
see who it is
anybody else
[Music]
did you turn the lights off please
excuse me not you the lady b you put the
light off his in her faces
someone's
if you can if you if you want to film
please come to the front if you because
why they're not going to live
please
[Music]
you can't have your family members of
the public
so you need to come to the front
or you need to stop filming
stops
another okay thank you
uh Council Lawman
thank you chairman
um very very short really but I'm not
well I don't come from that cell to the
town
um I listened to what everybody's been
said and it's obviously an emotional
subject and I'm concerned about there's
nothing in this report and that I can be
advised on this uh that do that's
referred to the content of an
advertisement and it can be offensive
now offensive if you look at the public
order act can be quite a wide-ranging
issue and I look at what's going on here
and the emotions involved and the
history which I'm fully aware of of this
site I find it very insensitive of law
to put the words coming soon it's almost
like a wipe in the eye it's almost an
intimidation to local people and I'm
concerned that this is could be a public
order issue and
um you've only got to listen to the
people and the lady was talking at the
end earlier on she talked about the
impact of advertisements on signs and
yet there's no reporting about how or
what about that sign there's no
consideration in this report about what
that sign says maybe the sunrise it may
be its color but there's nothing about
its content and I'm concerned about his
company because I think putting it there
is an intimidation to the local people
and it could could cause public order in
the future which I would oppose the
other thing is of course I don't think
it's in keeping with the street scene
sticking it where it is it could be
further back it could be somewhere else
does it have to be the size but I don't
think it's in keeping with the street
scene so I think that all in all I think
that this is a rather a
precarious uh request I think or
application and and I feel that I'm a
little bit concerned about the reasoning
behind this sign of what it can change
so it's the wording of the sign not the
size of the sign that I think is an
issue for me in terms of amenities the
impact on the local population if you
like I don't live that way so I'm not
going to get involved in that but that's
my concern and we don't we should be
designing our crime that's my thing
thank you okay see what you
lights come back on that now we'll wait
till the end
if you can come back on for the message
on the sign
um
I think that's for members to make their
own judgment on
okay fine uh councilor creeps I think is
next
yeah
um
I'm not all counselor in this area but I
have spotted something on the key
document that that term
drawing that's up there
[Music]
it talks about the sign support polls
and there's a little cubby out there
which says the length of the poles will
be dependent on ground clearance I see
no reason why that Dimension couldn't
have been fixed
because otherwise the pole could be
higher
than the 4.25 meters is based on so it's
a bit of wriggle room now on how either
side might be
to compound that there's another
wriggle room note on that drawing
it shows
the subject display that's just been
mentioned but next to it it says example
text shown indicative only
I see that as a wriggle room for that
sign being bigger different color
more intimidating
they need to be pinned down on that I
will Echo councilor Orton's point about
Blue's attitude to compliance and so on
and I don't believe we should let that
go through like that because it will be
bigger it will be different and why is
that important I'll tell you why it's
important I've read the Town and Country
act in respect to this and it places
massive emphasis on obstruction
a sign mustn't
obliterate a road sign it mustn't block
a camera it mustn't block a line of
sight when you move on to look at
distraction as opposed to obstruction
it says very little
and it's reflected in here where ECC
make a judgment that it's not
distraction
it's not evidence-based it's an opinion
and likewise our officers have followed
It Up by citing two apparently similar
signs elsewhere which is I won't labor
the point but the two examples are
nothing like this scenario that we've
got here
cycle track crossing lights children
whatever it's nothing like that it's on
the edge of the two sites
actually stood in front of empty Fields
when these signs were put up
that's where they were located so I
didn't say that was fair so I like
everybody else but I will add one last
thing
putting it where they put it
shows no consideration at all on their
part
you cannot see the site from ashington
road so don't have to go there it could
go somewhere neutral up the road if if
you were thinking about it why would you
put it right in the middle of the
problem area
I just I just don't understand the
reasoning beyond that and I wouldn't
support this you know thank you
[Applause]
counselor Stanley
thank you chairman
um I'd just like to
point out to the committee
that uh on page 8.4 and 3.4
in front of us says policy dm37
and it states that the design and
sighting of advertisement throughout the
district must have regard to the access
and visual impact of the buildings on
which they will be displayed and the
character of the surrounding area
with the character of the surrounding
area has no Billboards on it
has no signs other than road safety
signs
and this what they're aiming to do is
something similar to what you've got
behind you where it says Roxford
District Council imagine those larger
than those being put up cause they're a
distraction of course drivers will go
hey yeah I've never seen that before
those signs are there to to cause that
to cause that distraction we want you
coming soon sort of thing
so I do find and with the comments made
by my colleague just a moment ago that
there's wiggle room
um I would like to make this a motion to
refuse this application please thank you
so we have us
second different motion
counselor web
yeah we've got a motion on the table so
let's
counselor Steptoe next but it speaks an
emotional refusal or not the thing
[Music]
sounds like chairman I'd like some
points of clarification please
um if you can go back to where the
picture of the Bell Mouse of the
entrance is please
okay where's the Triangular stand sign
is standing is that the original grass
Verge
I take it the little sort of wavy line
behind the sign to the right as we look
at it is the original boundary property
property boundary
okay said you want to come back on that
yeah so this is the original boundary is
that what you're no the frontage
boundary oh here oh it was that's the
original Frontage boundary I mean the
measurements are taken from the
carriageway and the footway okay so the
the wavy line that's just to the right
of the sign that's the original building
oh this line here yes yes the outline of
the house tomorrow thank you now the
sign itself has obviously got to be
secured to the ground
what information do you have on how that
is going to be dealt with
we don't have the information but it
wouldn't be something that we
necessarily need to have
um it would need to be secured but the
the tests that we have to consider the
application for an advertisement on or
in relation to amenity so not relevant
to to that because below ground and
Public Safety there are standard
conditions that are required to be
imposed on adverts to make sure that
they don't pose a danger as in they
don't you know they must be secure so
that they don't fall over in high winds
which has been mentioned or previously
yeah I've seen major road signs uh like
around by the airport uh industrial
estate there was a big sign there that
fell over in the wind so and I'm pretty
sure that was Secure so I do have a
concern about that
um you also mentioned in your report
that the the lifespan of where the PSI
will be is limited to when people start
to cross the road by foot
do you like to hear that correct
um well yes that and
um
of that access
when it is
complete in its approved form for
vehicle traffic
and those two things would happen likely
simultaneously so when the access is
complete unable to be used for vehicular
traffic you'd expect them pedestrians to
be Crossing at around this point here or
directed to cross about this point here
okay thank you and the final point I
wanted to raise was and I'm sure you'll
you'll know the uh the signage that I'm
talking about
if you take on board the signs that have
been put up in Saturn Road where the
football training ground has been put
those signs were put up as safety
barriers
barrier but they do display Southend
United quite prominently
if we didn't give permission for this
sign
would the developer be quite entitled to
put those up without planning permission
so
[Music]
so in terms of I think what you're
getting at is like a full back position
so if this were refused tonight what um
deemed consent might the developer
benefit from and the average regulations
are quite complex I don't have a copy of
them before me
um and so I can't give you precise
details of what may be available to the
developer to put up in the form of
advertising if this particular
application were refused
thank you
okay
okay uh Council of Eves
I'm not sure whether I can continue with
what I was going to say because
unfortunately counselor Stanley has cut
off the debate by putting a proposal on
the table so are we allowed to
um
yeah okay no that's it my opportunity's
gone then thank you that's the Mason
should I switch to the proposal one
disabled
Mason sorry
I know I'm picky about that right
um
the purpose of a hoarding is
by definition
is to attract attention
so in a prominent position
it is going to attract attention
and therefore will be distracting to
passing traffic
the fact that other sites have hoardings
does not make this one in such a
sensitive location right
this is not South End
City sorry it's a city or Brentwood
O'Reilly but this is a relatively rural
residential area
and this will have an adverse impact on
the visual immunity for the residents in
that area
it is totally out of keeping
so I will support refusal
because
and I've made some notes Here is it
prominent it's in an overbearing and
will provide a distraction for vehicle
traffic and consequently May attack
attract affect Public Safety
and visual amenity is another concern
visual immunity is subjective I think in
the report it says that it's considered
acceptable well I don't consider it
acceptable in this location so I would
certainly support the motion on the
table for refusal thank you thank you
like councilor Stanley you put motion on
the table for refusal can I have your
reasons to refusal please
thank you if I'd like to ask the officer
if this was to go forward could we ask
or are we allowed to ask them to move
the sign back below behind the line of
houses would that be allowed
yes that would be whether I could make
my decision on refusal so I'm asking the
officer whether that sign could be
allowed to be moved back or would be
allowed to ask them to move it back okay
thank you
so members have to determine the
application before you tonight and we
have already asked law to to move it
back so what we haven't shown is the
original proposal which had that sign
positioned essentially well much closer
to the the footway so closer to
ashington road so this is the proposal
before you I don't think it would be
appropriate if members were so minded to
impose a condition to recite it I think
you have to consider the proposal as
cited okay thank you thanks for the
spelling
yep yeah thank you chairman uh two
questions for the officer if I may
please the position of this proposed
sighting of the board I assume is on the
left-hand corner of what is currently
the potential entrance that they're
working into going into at the moment
yes yeah having gone down there today to
look at this
um you've said earlier on uh that the
board would stay in place until the
roadway is in actual full use the way
the amount of traffic that was going in
out there this morning when I went down
there I would say it's already in full
use
so
you know really we're looking at a
situation that has already been
overtaken thank you chairman thank you
all right everybody more or less
everybody's had a chance to speak now I
don't see more hounds today so we've got
a motion on the table we've got motion
for refusal and I need to be reasons for
refusal cancer standings in Virginia
motion so if you'd like to give us a
reason for refusal uh thank you chairman
um
the motion is
it doesn't comply to dm37 in the way of
characteristic to the surrounding areas
and overbearing sign
for that area
okay thank you any other
reasons for refusal cancer Crips
the commission at the site is open to
operate oh sorry
the definition of the sign is open to
interpretation on that drawing thank you
councilor Webb
School the other examples in the report
that are given are in completely
different areas this is in the middle of
a busy residential area opposite of
school where 500 pupils and parents come
out daily okay councilories I think you
had your hand up
yeah following up from councilor
sperrying I was going to actually say
exactly what he was going to say in that
the section 3.18
negates this sign at this particular
point in time anyway because the actual
wording there is the applicant is also
advised the proposed sign will be
removed upon first use of approved
future vehicle access to the development
side it's already been used thank you
councilor Mrs Mason did you hand your
hand up
yes thank you I think it's been covered
but I'll just
confirm that we have visual immunity as
I said it's out of keeping with the
residential area and the aspects of
Public Safety and certainly I think the
item that counts the sparing and Eaves
have brought to our attention should
also be in the reviews or thank you okay
thank you if you obviously got those
reasons okay
members
um sorry
I've got to say do not come back just
for clarity because obviously there is a
right to appeal and we need to be sure
we've captured everything
um so that we can make points if if
necessary at an appeal
um so I think what I've understood is
that the first reason for refusal is all
about
um that first matter on which adverts
can be determined is visual amenity is
it harmful to visual amenity
um and I think what I've heard tonight
is that's to do with its size and scale
citing it being a residential area and
then there is a reference in there to
dm37 in terms of the character of the
local area as well
that would be a reason on its own okay
distinct from another reason which
relates to the second matter that
adverts can be determined on which is
Public Safety and I've understood that
um members view is that the other
examples that have been referred to are
not
um similar of characteristics and this
is somewhat unique in terms of its
sighting outside a school
um and the I've made some other notes
about about the points in relation to
the specifics and the crossing
um in close proximity as well but what I
just would CL like Clarity on is I think
in relation to Public Safety there has
also been mentioned sorry I've lost the
page now
um
in relation to the actual wording that's
going on the sign and I just like
confirmation that it is members in
members view that this reason for
refusal on Public Safety should also
include and it's referenced on paragraph
3.3 on page 8.14
um
so the last sentence of that paragraph
says planning practice guidance advises
lpas that unless the nature of the
advertisement is in itself harmful to
amenity or Public Safety consent cannot
be refused
for example I've been given one example
that that
um planning practice relied guidance
relates to but is it your view that the
blah wording is by its very nature
harmful to Public Safety
okay thank you and so we we understand
then that that second reason relation to
Public Safety will include that element
as well okay
I think we've got it on it also says
that advertisement unnecessary
unnecessary so that is sorry it's clear
the planning practice guns is clear that
lpas cannot refuse just because we
consider an advert to be unnecessary but
your view is that it's the wording that
um potentially harmful to Public Safety
okay right members do we have motion on
the table we can
Doncaster can I just make sure we
understand or that it's clarified that
in what I observed this morning
it's a mute consideration as to whether
that roadway is already in full use
my view was that it is
yeah just to come back and so
um I have seen photographs of the
progress of that access and being put in
and the the photographs I've seen has a
vehicle on that
um it is within the site so in this area
here I'm not aware that vehicles are
exiting onto ashington they are okay so
members of public please so please be
quiet please so what I would say is if
members were minded to approve we would
have to maybe
um rethink if you considered it
acceptable for this sign to be in place
were
um Vehicles exiting and entering the
site here okay
um but I don't think that's
might not be necessary to to think about
that but if it is we can come to that
and whether that condition needs to be
reworded okay members we have
a motion on the table for refusal
please please members of the public
please be quiet
thank you
members we have motion on the table to
refuse it's been seconded so can I have
now can I please we need to move on can
I have a show of hands please for
refusal
think that's unanimous
[Applause]
members it's coming up to 10 o'clock we
need to make take a vote if we want to
carry on this meeting past 10 o'clock
Okay so
okay members we should at least try to
can we try and do one more because we've
got just one more
so can I have a vote to extend a meeting
about half an hour
okay remember can we have a vote losing
cover seconder
opposing favors to extend the meeting
extend the meeting by half an hour to
half ten
those in favor please
those against
two three four five six
we're going to extend the meeting by
half an hour to half ten we're off the
chairman to come back some like to get
to chairman
now she's
foreign
for the next
Ginger item
please
[Music]
members can we please uh come back to
the table so we can start the next item
please
councilor Lawman please can you come
back to the table please
councilor Eaves can you come back to the
table please counselor Lawman
Council Lawman can you no can you please
come back we need to start this off this
matey
no council Longman
can you please sit down I can't keep
repeating myself thank you
I yeah but unfortunately
you can't do it and you're not his
counselor
thank you
[Music]
I know but no counselor we because you
voted I understand to carry this on for
for half an hour
foreign
[Music]
right excuse me Council Allman I was not
telling you to bugger off in your words
so I'd like to call this meeting to
order or I'll stand up and close the
meeting and that these members were a
residents will have wasted their time
which I do not want this to happen thank
you
right so I understand even though I
wasn't here that it was voted on
to extend the meeting to half past 10.
am I right thank you so we're now on Cut
item seven
okay
[Music]
no I'll bring sorry Katie
oh
no apparently we don't because
we would prefer me not to be here
push yourself
she wasn't in the meeting at the time
right okay let's have another vote to
extend this until half past tense no
right because I wasn't in the room the
rest a couple of the committee would
like this done members can I please ask
that we extend this to half past 10 the
meeting can I have a show of hands
please
it's fine yep that's fine that's a grade
thank you item seven
bear with me members
right agenda item seven twenty two zero
zero five six three four land
north of Chichester Hall
Farm old London
Katie Fowler will
present the officer's report please
thank you chairman the site is located
to the north of Chichester Hall farm and
is situated between the a130 and a1245
and is within close proximity to two
other football clubs so on the screen we
have an aerial image this is the site
here just go around with the laser
um and then this site here is one other
football club as well as this site and
then we have the a130 here and then the
a1245 here
um if I just go
you can see a zoomed in version of the
site and then some site photos
which show the field as existing with so
nut grass seed
and just to show this image with the
book that goes around the outside of the
site
and then the highway of old London wrote
the site is located within the
Metropolitan Greenbelt and there are two
public rights of way which run through
the site
um you should be able to see on this
image the one that runs to the North and
then the run one that runs to the east
is also located within flood zones two
and three as demonstrated by the EA map
on the screen and is also at high risk
of surface water flooding as shown on
the screen
I'll just zoom this one out so we can
see it in full
plan of a mission is sought for the
proposed change of use of land the land
to form 10 football pitches training
area and site storage changing
containers with Associated parking and
the creation of an access road and
vehicular access the facility would be
used by raylee Town youth football club
during the summer months the pitches
would be operational but most days
between 2PM to 7pm and all day Saturdays
and Sundays during winter months this
would be restricted to 10 a.m to 3 P.M
at the weekends only
there are a substantial number of
reasons for refusal recommended with
this application which I have explored
in depth within the officer report I
will outline the considerations of this
application but for the car but for
clarity the reasons for refusal relate
to the impact on trees impact on
neighbors lack of disabled parking
spaces inadequate parking base sizes
obstruction of two public rights of way
failure to pass the sequential test
incompatibility between the proposed use
and purpose of the flood zone lack of
information to demonstrate that the
proposal could suitably mitigate against
flood risk impact upon protected species
impact upon designated sites and then
lastly
the insufficient evidence to demonstrate
that the site could not be located
within Rayleigh where there is an
identified deficit of plane pitches
so moving on to those considerations we
look firstly at the Greenbelt policy
the use of the site for outdoor sport is
considered to be an appropriate use
within the green belt as according to
National policy the introduction of
storage containers ought to lose and a
car park have also been proposed to
facilitate this use similar scales of
facilities have been accepted on nearby
football pitch sites and they are an
appropriate use of land in association
with the outdoor sport use of a site the
vehicles used in the car park would not
have a permanent impact on the green
Bill the impact on the green book could
be minimized through the conditioning
through conditioning parts of the scheme
as the location of Porter cabins and the
materials of the hard standing
the development would be compliant with
green belt policy in this regard
views of the site would be largely
contained by the existing and proposed
landscape features the site would
maintain the landscape character of the
site with hedgerows being subject to
enhanced measures the site is classified
as grade 3 land by the agricultural land
classification however it is not
considered that the proposal would
result in a permanent impact on the
agricultural land
despite not being shown on the submitted
site plan the drainage plan detailed two
ponds
at present there is a lack of detail to
demonstrate that the pond shown on the
drainage plan would not have an impact
upon the trees this could therefore lead
to a detrimental impact upon the
character and value of the Farmland
setting and would be country to policy
dm1 and dm-25 as well as the mppf this
is that's the first recommended reason
for refusal
in terms of Heritage The Proposal is not
considered to impact upon nearby listed
buildings and the application could be
conditioned to secure the implementation
of an archaeological investigation where
it being recommended for approval
the application site is located nearby
to a number of residential dwellings um
on the screen you can see guamas Lodge
which is located immediately adjacent
here
the development would result in an
increase of generations to the site as
well as vehicle movement movements
within the site the use of the site
would also result in an activity being
present for a significantly increased
period Then what is experienced
currently
no noise survey has been provided with
the application to enable the local
authority to properly analyze the
estimated noise levels and their impact
on neighboring properties
no mitigation has been proposed either
the council's environmental health
officer has identified that there would
be the potential for noise disturbance
to existing Neighbors The Proposal is
considered to have the potential to
result in unacceptable noise levels that
have not been addressed or attempted to
be mitigated contrary to policy dm1 and
the amppf this has led to the second
recommended reason for refusal
a transport assessment was submitted
with the application which modeled the
trip rate for the proposed use
transport statement had predicted that
the use would generate up to 62 vehicle
trips during typical Sunday peak hours
however the transport statement
indicates that these trips would not be
new or additional trips but rather
transferred from a combination of the
Rayleigh football club boys and girls
and Rayleigh sports and social club
where the club that is subject to this
application currently use pitches
um so the Rayleigh football club boys
and girls currently operate from this
site which is opposite on Old London
Road and then Rayleigh sports and social
club run from London Road in Rayleigh
so on that basis the transport
assessment has assumed and even slip a
split of the transfer trips between the
two existing sites meaning that 31 trips
are already occurring on Old London Road
due to the use of Rayleigh boys football
club
this concurs that at most the proposed
development would result in a 15.1
percent increase in traffic however the
Asian emailed officers following the
publication of the report in an in an
attempt to overcome other objections
in doing so they did not manage to
overcome these objections but um did
state that the transport statement was
actually incorrect the emark explicitly
stated that under no circumstances have
raylee Town Youth Football Club used the
site adjacent to the proposed site at
Old London Road Rally boys football club
and so this site which runs opposite on
which they were using as justification
for the trip generation
in this regard the application is absent
of a transport statement which provides
an accurate trip generation analysis as
the development would have far greater
impact than the statement alludes to on
this basis the youth club on the basis
at the youth football club do not use
old London Road at present
although new vehicle access posed this
has not been objected to by the highway
Authority and so we do not raise
objection to that part
however it is still considered the
proposal would have the potential to
severely impact the highway Network to
the detriment of Highway Safety it is
recommended that an additional 12th
reason for refusal is imposed in
relation to this and if you just bear
with me I will pull up the wording onto
the screen so that hopefully
you can see that to zoom in
so this wording says in the absence of
an accurate transport assessment to
sufficiently assess the highway impact
of the development the local planning
Authority are unable to determine
whether the proposal would result in a
trip generation that would have an
unacceptable impact on highway safety
contrary to bar graph one one one of the
mppf
if you just bear with me I'll go back to
the plan
um in terms of the parking the power
parking stages set out the requirements
for team sport parking provisions and
that is also set out within the office
of report
the proposed development would provide
182 car parking spaces 10 powered
two-wheelers 30 cycle spaces and one
coach Bay however no blue badge spaces
have been depicted on the plan and the
requirement for this would be 11 spaces
the power parking standards are clear
that it is the responsibility of the
site occupies under the disability
Discrimination Act 2005 to ensure that
adequate provision is made for the needs
of people with disabilities
blue badge sprays are required to be
longer and wider than the preferred base
size to ensure easy access from the side
and rear for those with wheelchairs and
this protects people with disabilities
from moving traffic
there are no spaces proposed which will
be capable of accommodating the blue
badge base size further the base size of
the parking spaces would be around the
minimum dimensions
the transport statement states that the
minimum Bay size has been used utilized
to ensure that all parking can be
contained on site however the preferred
base size could could have been adhered
to when the layout was created we would
not be able to impose a condition to
increase the scale of the
parking Bays to adhere to the parking
standards as this would require
additional hard standing and further
calculations of surface water runoff and
this would affect the drainage proposed
they were not considered to be
exceptional circumstances which justify
the use of minimum Bay sizes in this
case and the use of these could lead to
on-site parking if vehicles that did not
meet did not fit into these Bays were
brought onto site the development has
therefore failed to provide adequate
parking Dimensions on-site for disabled
parking bays and regular parking Bays
contrary to the Oppo parking standards
policy dm30 and th and this has led to
the third and fourth recommended reasons
for refusal
as outlined at the start there are two
public raise which run through the site
and this has been demonstrated at the
start
and the footpath would be obstructed by
part of the internal Access Road some of
the parking spaces are now adjacent to
the west of the seven by seven pitches
and the 11 first 11 football pitches
objection has been raised from Essex
County Council and spaces and this forms
the fifth recommended reason for refusal
an air quality assessment was submitted
and this has been outlined in the report
the environmental health officer
concluded that this was satisfactory and
subject to a condition where the
application being recommended for
approval
so moving on to flood risk the site is
within flood zones two and three in the
first instance we require the
development to pass the sequential test
and the flood risk assessment was absent
of this and we concluded that given the
extent of Greenbelt in the in the
district it would be likely that this
use could be accommodated outside of the
flood zone
The Proposal would also be required to
be assessed against the exceptions test
and this pointed out that because of the
location of the development within flood
zone 3B specifically it was not
compatible with a functional floodplain
and the development would therefore be
inappropriate for its flood zone and
Falls forms the seventh recommended
reason for refusal
the mppf is clear of what is required in
a flood risk assessment and these
requirements can be summarized as
ensuring the most vulnerable development
is located in areas at lowest risk of
flooding the use of flood resilient and
resistant methods the incorporation of
Suds residual risk being safely managed
and a safe access and Escape Route that
is identified as part of an emergency
plan the submitted flood risk assessment
identifies a residual risk to be from
the defense failure but fails to
demonstrate that this could be safely
managed further the fra does not outline
that safe access and egress would be
possible during a flood event
the sod's features to deal with surface
water runoff from the access road and
parking areas as permeable Paving
however the lead local flood Authority
have issued a holding objection due to
the inadequate modeling used and lack of
evidence that the sub scheme would be
suitable
further the sad scheme proposes to drain
the runoff into avoided subbase from
which it would be attenuated and
partially discharged into the ground and
existing Watercourse it's not clear from
the fra why this hybrid solution has
been chosen no final drainage plan which
depicts the exceedance and conveyance
routes Finnish flood levels and ground
levels and location and sizing of the
drainage features has been submitted the
LFA have also issued a holding objection
due to the absence of this information
the development has therefore the
potential to increase flood risk from
both River and surface water sources and
would inadequately mitigate against
these risks contrary to national and
local policy and this forms the eighth
recommended reason for refusal
the site is a large field and has been
planted with a grass seed and is
surrounded by hedgerows and ditches part
the hedrow had been removed but enhanced
permissions including replanting has
been proposed to mitigate against this
the application site would form a
suitable habitat for Great Crested news
bats for reptiles and breed Birds
however the site has not been surveyed
for these protected species and no
mitigation has been suggested to prevent
harm during the construction phase
whilst the submitted preliminary
ecological appraisal did state that some
of these surveys had been prepared they
were not submitted with the application
and this therefore forms the night's
recommended reason for refusal
a habitat regulation assessment had been
has been carried out due to the site's
proximity to a number of designated
sites the development has been
identified by Natural England as having
the potential to impact upon winter and
birds in which the European protected
data designated for
upon completion of the habitat
regulations assessment it was evident
that there is currently insufficient
information provided with the
application to determine whether the
likelihood of significant effects can be
ruled out and natural and concerning
advice is that in that case proposals
should be refused and this therefore
forms the 10th recommended reason for
refusal
in terms of lighting there is no light
and proposed so we have no objection on
that basis
um and then the last consideration is to
do with playing pitches and so there are
a number of local policies which seek to
enhance and preserve Community
facilities one of them being policy dm16
which outlines that playing pitches will
be permitted provided that they are
proposed in an area where a deficit in
supply has been identified by the
playing pitch strategy the strategy
identifies that Rayleigh has a deficit
of playing pitches whereas roarwith is
one of the only areas where there is a
surplus
policy dm16 does allow for alternative
locations where a deficit has not been
identified to be permitted and list the
number of circumstances however it has
not been identified that any of these
circumstances comply and in this case
the proposal locate is located outside
of an area where the deficit and
therefore the application has failed to
demonstrate why the development could
not be located in an area with a deficit
such Israeli then the proposal would be
contrary to dm16 on that basis and forms
the 11th reason sorry 40 11th roots in
for refusal
the application is recommended for
refusal chairman for the reasons outline
within the officers report and the
additional reason presented to members
this evening thank you
we have also I do apologize we have our
first speaker for this is councilor
Matthews or from Roth Parish Council
please
as before this uh councilor Matthews
there's five minutes to speak and I will
let you know when you've spoken for four
thank you thank you madam chairman
rors has accommodated enough sports
facilities particularly football
this site is unsuitable for a variety of
reasons
if granted for five years what guarantee
will activity cease for example
the land is classified agriculturally as
3B which at the moment has no formal
protection
but there is imminent government
legislation proposed to protect it for
food production against unsuitable
development
the land is very low lying with very
little gradient on two sides there are
Brooks which often over top
drainage will be an issue which could
limit its use as football pitches during
the winter months
in view of the district council's
decision to rewild some of their
existing Playing Fields because of
unsuitable drainage and in some cases
lack of demand
this area is far worse
in Wildlife terms this football years
will reduce the attraction to some
species including invertebrates and
birds
one has to see what is happening now in
Morris
will be a repeat of the football desert
in no kill and barley lands
which is wholly unattractive visually
there is possibly a badger set on the
boundary which could be abandoned
through disturbance as well as as
already been mentioned the Great Crested
newts at Chichester Hall
parking and speeding is already a big
issue along Old London Road
the road is de-restricted between the 30
mile limit in Church Road and the
junction with London Road where a 40
mile an hour limit is in force eastwards
The Junction is inadequate and
potentially dangerous to intermittent
heavy traffic from the many pitches
present and proposed
the site is remote and entails car usage
only
the parish council and residents have
been pressing for improvements and speed
limits over many years with County
some promises but no action
the disturbance now being suffered by
residents is at times intolerable and in
a rural era unsatisfactory
often met with verbal abuse and in one
case physical abuse by selfish parking
on Old London Road itself
with the as promised construction of new
all-weather pitches at the Leisure
Center and Clements Hall this will
reduce drastically the demand for
facilities elsewhere
multiple use can be made by them from
early morning to late evening for
training and matches this will reduce
car usage and provide provide valuable
revenue for the council's leases
this land should remain in food
production as we enter into an era of
potential food shortages with an
uncertain International climate
also to reduce food miles and our carbon
footprint
thank you for the opportunity to address
this meeting
and Infuse the documented and local
opposition we hope each individual
counselor would consider both the local
issues as well as the greater picture
which are a reflection of the emerging
concerns about land usage
many of our concerns have already been
addressed in the officer's report to
which we may which we agree with thank
you for your time
councilor Matthews
Mr David Collins
is on our next speaker in in an
objection to the application
thank you Mr Collings again you will
have five minutes to speak
yeah sorry I'm looking at you
yeah and I'll I'll let you know when
you've spoken off before thank you my
name is Dave Collins and I've lived in
Old London Road for the past 50 years
I and all the residents of old London
Road and Church Road very strongly
opposed A planning application for the
following reasons traffic the amount of
traffic already generated on Old London
Road and Church Road is becoming
intolerable I've already presented and
proven regular weekend football related
traffic flows which equates to 2090 car
movements as car movements not cars
per day
this summer passed a tournament on
Rayleigh boys sites which is opposite
this proposed sites generated at least
3040 car movements
this figure does not include Academy
soccer which is another site that is
further up the road which would increase
the traffic flow to at least 4 000 car
movements
all this traffic is using a
de-restricted Road 60 mile an hour limit
with no payments forcing local residents
to take their lives into their own hands
if they want to walk the road
if planning permission is granted for
this new site opposite Rayleigh boys the
traffic will be impossible to control
earlier last year about this time last
year highways did put
a traffic counter in the road
but it rained for a fortnight and the
fields wasn't used by Rayleigh boys for
a month so it's completely useless
because nobody went across the brass
strip to uh to count the traffic because
there was no traffic to count so that
was a waste of time
um
the traffic will be impossible to
control I know that is the intention to
construct a bridge across the brook in
Old London Road onto the site this will
have the effect of forcing traffic to
queue while the traffic is turning right
onto the bridge
on leaving the site turn left onto Old
London Road immediately after the severe
Bend outside goemers Lodge my property
in the last three years I've had two
motorbikes and a car in January 22 crash
into my front garden and in May 22 a car
was driven straight off the bend into
the brook and the damage is still there
if anybody would care to see it
the site entrance is not too far away
from this uh severe Bend and it will be
very precarious place and it will
no doubt in just a matter of time before
a very serious accident occurs
no it's a nuisance the noise of
Spectators shouting and referees were
blind is detrimental to the residents of
the area
it's now not advisable for us to have a
barbecue a garden party because of the
traffic and the noise generated by all
the football teams which are saturated
in the area
it is noted that Academy soccer of a
party to use their site seven days a
week
so it begs the question when do the
residents get a break
from the interference to our lives
Rochford District council's own
policy states environmental health noise
nuisance no unreasonable and significant
emission of noise that causes a
significant interference and
unreasonable interference with the use
and enjoyment of your premises
by definition this forms
a nuisance in terms of environment
agency acts and environment protection
act 1960.
the flood risk the proposed site is in a
very high flood risk area an old London
Road from the a129 to coimbers Lodge is
sometimes impassable due to flooding
Rory flat Action Group has had numerous
meetings with the environment agency
Essex County Council in Rochford
District Council regarding severe
flooding in the area and recently
desilting Works have been started to
help alleviate the problem with this
application regarding earthbounds
construction of a bridge car parking
sets will only increase the flooding
risk in the area which is already at
severe risk of flooding
have been formed by the
eida if works are carried out on the
riverbank is equal to cause a problem
further Downstream with the right
parents right act this is exactly what
will happen
uh the environment that is proposed to
construct a car park directly on top of
public footpowers and aging rights of
ways there are two family footballs on
this site which must have been deserved
there are protective species on the site
Great Crested newts plus other Wildlife
such as buzzards egrets herons which
must not be disturbed
the application is for a temporary
five-year license
for 10 football pitches what happens
after five years who would who would
invest in excess of half a million pound
with this short period will the land be
restored to its original state and
purpose agricultural
that's it just finished oh just finished
thank you very much thank you
are there any visiting members wishing
to speak on this please
shakes ahead no okay visiting members
um I'll ask the committee members now to
speak the war counselors are Council
Crips and councilor Stanley first so
would you uh cut the scripts first and
then councilor Stanley thank you
thank you
it's a very extensive and comprehensive
officers report covering numerous
aspects so I'm not going to drill down
there on second guess
oh there will therefore will limit my
observation to
put in the
officer's report paragraph 3.168 page
7.36 cancer crits can you talk into the
mic please sorry
you know put on the point about downers
doubt downhill and roarth
having a surplus of outdoor sports
facilities
I've looked on
the aerial map dropped a pin in the
middle of this
proposed site gone Northeast 900 meters
and it lands in the middle of roarth
Park that the parish councilor mentioned
it's huge it's two big rectangular
fields
it benefits from not being Category 3
flood zone
seems to me
a short-term five-year project could
easily be accommodated on there
and avoiding many of these
environmental issues and traffic issues
and flooding issues it just seems that
the search for pitches in Riley is not
that very far away from here and I just
type to emphasize that point thank you
just to clarify you did have a question
that you didn't have a question for the
officers did you on that
sorry no I just want to clarify you
don't need the officers to come back no
as I said it's comprehensive and
extensive yeah thank you very much I
just want your clarification Council
Stanley
thank you chairman
um
the previous speaker spoke about
playing fields at rorif at the top of
Rory flowing
there is ample Park in there and the
last time I remember visiting that Park
was to actually turn the football
pitches into a wild flower Meadows
now this seems to be an ideal situation
for the football to be carried out there
um of which I met Adam albidge Who is
the
operation uh officer
and we looked at changing those pitches
too as I say Wild Flower Meadows
so why don't we use those instead
plus the fact that the officer has done
a massive report here spent a great deal
of time
on this
and I believe that we should put a
motion forward to refuse as to what the
officers have indicated thank you
right have we got a set we've got a
motion on the table to
refuse this and councilor FD has
seconded it
members we're gonna now speak of the
motion for refusal
uh does council Roman do you need to
still speak
thank you very much councilor FD
the recommended recommendation is for
refusal there's 12 recommendations for
refusal I suggest we just go straight to
the vote on this yep
right members we've got the motion on
time what's been seconded and the
recommendation is for a refusal can't
have all members who once it refused to
indicate please
remember that is unanimous thank you
thank you very much members
we're not going to get the others in are
we Council close the meeting
I'm not staying any longer
yeah wait a minute I've just got to
clarify
I'm not staying any longer I've got a
meeting in the morning I'm not staying
much like we can't remember if they want
it
foreign
close this meeting a half past 10.
um I've been a five-week should do
Barling Road
um 31 Barley Road members are you uh
content to carry on this meeting can I
have a vote please
yes
can you mark up Mike please Steptoe
sorry
German if we don't debate darling Road
does that fall fail of non-determination
regulations
we're just checking the target date
but the trouble is
where I don't think actually members
were going to be able to do this and
we're not going to be able to do this
application in eight minutes so it's I
would prefer to close the meeting now
and debate both of these uh nine and ten
properly because I don't feel that uh
knowing we can't do it in eight minutes
is uh Yvonne said and it will not be uh
debated correctly our members in
agreement with this please
thank you I will close the meeting at
10 25 thank you very much
[Music]